ooh sorry sweetie this chocolate bar is  actually really spicy I guess so  big news santa called he wants you to  take a nap all right you can stay out  here playing if you want just look out  for that bear I don't know what happened  to that very loud drum toy it must have  gotten stolen sorry honey the TV only  works when it's raining  oh honey Disneyland is closed today  Mickey Thicke actually if the ice cream  truck is playing music that means  they're out of ice cream  sorry sweetheart the soda actually has  coffee in it you wouldn't like it no  honey that animal at the side of the  road was just taking a nap okay fine I'm  leaving without you oh it's six o'clock  internet lady is turning off the world's  internet for the night I am serious  mister I'm starting the car right now  you know what happens if you don't  behave the drive-thru line they give you  a sad meal and we're gone got it Jackson  right now